et l'actualité c'est également le compte
du rassemblement national qui se tient
depuis hier à perpignan où marine le pen
a été sans surprise réélu à la tête du
parti pour un quatrième mandat
jordan barda l'air à 25 ans la
remplacera pendant la présidentielle un
scrutin sur lequel le rn compte beaucoup
surtout après sa défaite aux régionales
il n'y a pas de changement de ligne à
avoir puisque les élections régionales
finalement ont été les noms élections il
n'y a pas eu des lecteurs nos électeurs
ne se sont pas déplacés ça a été des
élections marquées par une abstention
massive terrifiante avec la reconduction
des candidats sortants 13 candidats
sortants donc ya pas de leçons en fait à
tirer de ces élections régionales et
départementales
nous on est clairement vers l'élection
présidentielle qui intéresse les
français et les élections régionales bon
et s a été un peu un échec mais est
finalement on s'en sort quand même pas
si mal
et puis à la présidentielle qui arrive
et ça c'est la mère de toutes les
batailles il va falloir qu'on marque on
amène qu'on envoie marine le pen à
l'elysée et là des lendemains des
élections régionales on était déjà sur
le terrain pour aller
rencontrer les gens et faire voter pour
marine le pen d'année prochaine